as perhaps 100 million Americans prepare
to watch tonight's first debate there's
something I'd like you to consider and
the first volume in this series of
comments I listed 176 reasons Donald
Trump cannot and must not be elected
president of the United States that list
was actually only half its original
length and it still took nearly 17
minutes to read aloud and since then to
my amazement I have discovered at least
two other lists that included dozens of
other events that had flown by in such
volume and so quickly that I had never
even noticed them to paraphrase William
Hurt in the movie body heat sometimes
the Trump comes down so heavy I feel
like I should wear a hat and it appears
it's now coming down heavier still what
follows is 74 more reasons Donald Trump
cannot and must not be elected president
of the United States there are a few
items from those other lists that I
mentioned but virtually everything you
will hear now has happened since just
the 9th of September the Republican
Party has actually nominated for
president a man who attacked Hillary
Clinton for contracting pneumonia who
attacked her and implied she was
concealing still other illnesses who
attacked her again with a false claim
that she wants to eliminate the Second
Amendment and then suggested her
bodyguards be disarmed and quote let's
see what happens to her who attacked her
a third time on Twitter just in case
anybody missed that dog whistle for
somebody to try to shoot her who
attacked her during the supposedly
nonpartisan speech to the poisoned water
victims of Flint Michigan who attacked
the pastor in Flint Michigan who
interrupted him and asked him to stop
attacking Clinton who attacked the
residents of Flint Michigan for their
crime rate who attacked the United
States is a quote third-world country
who attacked America's inner cities as
more dangerous than parts of Afghanistan
who attacked a former CIA director as
dopey after the man wrote an article
critical of him who attacked Maureen
Dowd of the New York Times after she was
critical of him in an interview and
called her a dope wacky neurotic crazy
who attacked the New York Times as a
quote laughingstock failing nuts
and claimed he talked his lawyers out of
suing them for irresponsible intent when
there is no such law legal term or
provision applicable to a newspaper who
attacked CNN and the network's president
personally after suggesting its
documentary about him was inaccurate
even though he had repeatedly said he no
longer ever watched CNN who attacked a
Fox News commentator confined to a
wheelchair as quote a guy that can't buy
a pair of pants who attacked Asian
businessmen in a stereotype accent
claiming they only say quote we want
deal who attacked Jewish businessmen
claiming I'm a negotiator like you folks
were negotiators and you're not going to
support me because I don't want your
money the Republican Party has actually
nominated for president a man who lied
about Hillary Clinton planning to
literally abolish American borders who
lied about whether or not Hillary
Clinton had begun birtherism who lied
about resolving birtherism who lied
about the nature of the hotel
promotional event at which he lied about
birtherism who seems to have lied about
why he finally formally backed away from
birtherism telling an Ohio TV station I
wanted to get on with the campaign who
lied about the term alt-right having
recently been quote made-up who lied
about the term alright having been
coined by Hillary Clinton who lied that
his answer to Howard Stern on September
11 2002 about whether this country
should go to war in Iraq was I don't
know when in fact it was yeah I guess so
and the answer is on tape who lied that
an interview with Sean Hannity in 2003
proved he was opposed to the Iraq war in
2002 when in fact he was recorded saying
Iraq quote looks like a tremendous
success who lied that a 2004 magazine
article proves he was opposed to the
Iraq war in 2002 who lied about how the
terrorist attack at the Bothell on Club
in Paris could have been averted if
attendees had been armed who lied about
how the african-american youth
unemployment rate is 58 percent when
it's actually 20
who lied to an audience that Hillary
Clinton is raising their taxes
substantially when her only proposed tax
increase applies only to the top 1% of
all earners who lied about Hillary
Clinton destroying 13 phones with a
hammer who lied about polls he claims
showing there was more enthusiasm for
him than for any previous presidential
candidate the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who claimed before investigators on the
scene of the explosion could or did
reach any conclusions that quote a bomb
unquote had gone off in New York City
who claimed our quote extremely open
immigration system was responsible for
the bombing even though the suspect
arrested was an American citizen with no
known connection to international
terrorism who claimed that he could
stand in New York City and shoot people
and not lose any supporters who claimed
that fed money policy was being
manipulated to politically benefit the
President of the United States who
claimed that Hillary Clinton is running
a hate-filled campaign during an event
in which one of his supporters was
filmed grabbing a protester by the neck
and punching him after which a 69 year
old woman protester was photographed on
the ground allegedly after being punched
by a man who claimed he knew Russia well
because he'd staged beauty pageants
there who claimed that Vladimir Putin
called him a genius when the Russian
word Putin used translates as colorful
or lively or flamboyant who claimed
after years of implying he had met him
and knew him well that quote honestly I
don't know Vladimir Putin who claimed in
an interview we did with Larry King that
ran on a network owned by the Kremlin
that he doubted that Russia which the US
government has claimed hacked the
Democratic National Committee was
attempting to disrupt the election who
claimed that the debates will be rigged
and thus should have no moderator who
claimed that he will replace Obamacare
with quote many different plans plans
you don't even know about health care
plans that will be so good who claimed
that his time at a military prep high
school gave him better military training
than a lot of people in
the military who claimed that American
wages are too high who seemed unable to
differentiate between Hamas and
Hezbollah who seemed unable to
differentiate between the Kurds and the
Kurds who claimed Belgium is a city who
claimed parts of London and Paris are so
filled with terrorists police are afraid
to go into them who claimed that he
keeps himself in good physical shape by
exercise consisting of making many hand
gestures while he gives speeches the
Republican Party has actually nominated
for president a man who has allied
himself with his son who made a
holocaust gas chamber joke about the
campaign who has allied himself with his
son who made a bizarre meme comparing
Syrian refugees to poisoned candies and
used a photo taken by a refugee who has
allied himself with Ben Carson who
responded to Hillary Clinton's pneumonia
by suggesting she get a specialized MRI
who has allied himself with the co-chair
of his veterans for Trump who insists
Secretary Clinton has Parkinson's
disease who has allied himself with his
latest campaign manager Kellyanne Conway
who insists Clinton has lied about her
pneumonia who has allied himself with
Conway even though when it was reported
that George HW Bush is voting for
Clinton she said I respect the 92 year
old former president very much as if his
age was the determining factor in his
voting choice who has allied himself
with Conway even though she denied there
should be extensive medical reporting on
Trump 16 days after Trump proposed both
camps released full medical records who
has allied himself with his running mate
Mike Pence who refused to call white
supremacist David Duke deplorable who
was aligned himself with his own
spokeswoman Katrina Pierson who publicly
assessed presidential candidates purity
of breeding the Republican Party has
actually nominated for president a man
who was revealed to have told Maureen
Dowd that there was nothing wrong with
violence at his rallies that had added
excitement whose campaign was then
revealed to have the same day while
Dowd's former assistant now a journalist
waited to find out if he would get
credentials to cover a trump speech
allowed the houston police to arrest the
man for trespassing
who was revealed to have announced the
New York pressure-cooker attacked within
minutes of the explosion but who waited
12 hours to express concern about the
victims who was revealed to have waited
24 hours to express concern about the
victims in the Minnesota stabbings who
has revealed to have waited thirty six
hours to express concern about the New
Jersey explosion who was revealed to
have then congratulated himself unquote
calling the New York bombing who was
revealed to have questioned why the
suspect in the New York bombing an
unconvicted American citizen was to
receive medical care a lawyer and food
who was revealed to have received 9/11
funds intended for small businesses who
was revealed to have told as many as
five separate lies about what he
personally did on 9/11 who was revealed
to have responded to 9/11 on 9/11 by
claiming a building he owned was now the
tallest in downtown Manhattan and it
wasn't even that who was revealed to
have spent $30,000 in Trump Foundation
charitable funds on portraits of himself
who was revealed to have spent five
thousand dollars in Trump Foundation
charitable funds on advertising for his
hotels who was revealed to have spent
two hundred fifty eight thousand dollars
in Trump Foundation charitable funds to
settle lawsuits against his for-profit
businesses who was revealed to have told
an interviewer that people living in
poverty are quote morons who was
revealed to have mused about deporting
Hillary Clinton who inexplicably
retweeted an article titled Trump's
birther event is the greatest trick he's
ever pulled and if that last one doesn't
sum up this campaign what could I'm
Keith Olbermann that's the closer watch
this space